[موسيقى]
ياتي هذا الشاب العماني كل يوم الى مكتبه
في منطقه بوشر بالعاصمه العمانيه مسقط
منهمكا لساعات طويله في انجاز مشروع الذي
يعتبره حلما لطالما اراد تحقيقه خليل
الحسيني شاب عماني يطمح الى توثيق التراث
الغذائي والماكولات العمانيه بطريقه فنيه
وابداعيه
[موسيقى]
مشروع الفنون طهي تحتها عده برامج نحن
جالسين نشتغل عليها اول برنامج اللي هو ان
نحن نعمل
مقاييس معايير للماكولات العمانيه بحيث
انه نحن ننتج كتاب من بعد الكتاب في برامج
كثيره ما نذكرها الحين لان شغالين فيها
واا على اساس فكره المشروع ما ما احد
ياخذها
خليل تجول في الكثير من المدن العمانيه
لتوفيق الاكلات مستفيدا من معلومات
الجمعيات المراه العمانيه في كل ولايه الى
جانب كبار السن حتى تمكن من توفيق اكثر من
90 اكله حتى الان
[موسيقى]
في عمان وصورنا اغلب الماكولات العمانيه
طبعا الماكولات العمانيه كثيره تتجاوز ال
120 اكل عمانيه نحنا صورنا ال ال ال
الماكولات النادره
همم
الناس ما تعرفك
[تصفيق]
يهدف الحسيني من خلال هذا المشروع الى
ترسيخ قيمه المروث الغذائيه العمانيه
وتشجيع الباحثين للاستثمار في مجالات
الطهي في الحقيقه احنا عندنا عده يعني
اهداف كثيره في المشروع
الهدف الاساسي ان نحن يكون عندنا محتوى في
الماكولات الفنون الطهي العماني نفس الشيء
امام
المجتمعولاتنا قبل ان احنا همم نسوقها
للخارج همم يكون عندنا اعتزاز همم
الناس بثقافه همم الفنون الطهي العماني
بحيث ان احنا همم
ننسخ في ال- همم في العالم ان احنا عندنا
اكل مميز ممكن الناس تجيء قريبا سيقوم
خليل الحسيني لاصدار كتاب لتصليط الضوء
على ذكر الموارد الاساسيه في طبخ
الماكولات في السلطنه كزراعه الثوم
والبصلي وصناعه ماء الوردي واللوبان
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من مسقط العربيه